[Música]
leyendo pasajes del corán luego dictará
las mujeres afganas a unirse a su
gobierno el grupo talibán señaló durante
su primera conferencia de prensa que
respetan los derechos de las mujeres
musulmanas pero bajo los principios de
la rigorista ley sharia
este martes un pequeño grupo de mujeres
manifestó en público su rechazo a los
talibán incluso un portavoz del grupo
insurgente fue entrevistado por una
periodista afgana en directo pero para
aquellas mujeres que vivieron bajo el
yugo de los fundamentalistas estas
promesas son sólo una cortina de humo
los talibanes dan mensajes
tranquilizadores sobre la concesión de
los derechos básicos de las mujeres
sobre la garantía de los derechos de las
mujeres pero su acción sobre el terreno
o sus prácticas son diferentes así que
ellas las mujeres tienen miedo tienen
miedo de volver o de ser encarceladas en
sus casas como lo hacían durante el
régimen talibán de 2001
wang generar la tercera ciudad más
grande de afganistán estas alumnas han
retomado esperanzadas las clases sin
dejar de lado el hiyab islámico que los
talibanes y exigen a las mujeres estamos
contentas de que nuestras escuelas hayan
comenzado y podamos continuar nuestros
estudios y esperamos que los talibanes
no obstaculicen nuestro progreso para
que podamos ayudar a nuestra nación a
desarrollarse como otros países es área
corazón las organizaciones de derechos
humanos y activistas feministas de la
región muestran su preocupación puesto
que durante el gobierno talibán entre
1996 y 2001 las mujeres y niñas fueron
despojadas de todos sus derechos
la posición de los talibanes es más o
menos la misma pero hemos visto pequeñas
diferencias especialmente en términos de
educación de las niñas
algunas analistas creen que este ligero
cambio de actitud es una máscara de cara
a la comunidad internacional